Lo cuestionan.
Lo siguiente es pensar una posible explicación para ese fenómeno:
una hipótesis.
Bien, ¿saben qué? Los océanos son azules.
Quizá el cielo refleja el color del océano.
¡Bien! Pero ahora hay que ponerlo a prueba.
Así que predicen cuáles podrían ser las implicancias.
Una predicción podría ser: "Bueno, si el cielo refleja el color del océano,
será más azul en las costas que en el centro del país".
Bien, tiene sentido, pero deben poner a prueba esa predicción.
Así que viajan en avión desde Denver, un agradable día gris,
hacia LA, levantan la vista y el cielo es de un glorioso azul.
¡Genial! Su tesis resultó correcta.
¿Pero lo es en verdad? No.
Realizaron una única observación.
Ahora necesitan analizar la hipótesis, pensar cómo ponerla a prueba
de distintas formas.
Quizá podrían ir a otra parte del país,
o viajar en otro momento del año y observar cómo es el clima entonces.
Otra buena idea es consultar con otras personas
que tengan ideas y perspectivas diferentes y que puedan ayudarlos.
Esto se conoce como revisión por pares.
Y, además, eso seguramente les ahorre tiempo y dinero,
pues no tendrán que viajar por todo el país para observar el clima.
Ahora bien,
¿qué pasa si su hipótesis es buena pero no perfecta?
Eso está bien, porque pueden modificarla un poco
y realizar el proceso de nuevo: hacer predicciones, ponerlas a prueba, etc.
Y al repetir varias veces este proceso, mejorarán su idea.
Y si la mejoran lo suficiente, puede ser aceptada por la comunidad científica,
al menos transitoriamente,
como una buena explicación de algún fenómeno,
al menos hasta que surja alguna idea mejor,
o evidencia que la contradiga.
Admitir los errores es parte del proceso,
y esto puede ser extremadamente difícil.
La ciencia posee fortalezas y debilidades que afectan esto.
Una de las fortalezas de la ciencia es que es desarrollada por personas,
y ha demostrado ser eficiente:
conocemos bastante bien el universo gracias a la ciencia.
Una de las debilidades de la ciencia es que es desarrollada por personas,
y llevamos muchas ideas preconcebidas a nuestras investigaciones.
Somos egocéntricos,
obstinados, supersticiosos,
tribales, humanos...
Son todas características humanas y los científicos son seres humanos.
Debemos ser conscientes de esto cuando estudiamos las ciencias
y cuando intentamos desarrollar nuestras propuestas.
Pero una parte de todo esto,
del proceso científico, del método científico,
es admitir nuestros errores.
Lo sé, me ha pasado.
Años atrás, cuando trabajaba en el telescopio espacial Hubble,
un científico colega me mostró unos datos y me dijo:
"Creo que esto puede ser la imagen de un planeta que orbita otra estrella".
Nunca antes se había tomado fotos de un planeta que orbitara otra estrella,
por lo que si esto era verdad,
se trataría de la primera fotografía
y nosotros seríamos quienes lo descubrieron.
Sería todo un acontecimiento.
Estaba muy entusiasmado, así que me puse a analizar estos datos.
Dediqué mucho tiempo a determinar si esto era un planeta o no.
El problema es que los planetas son opacos y las estrellas son brillantes,
por lo que conseguir una señal de estos datos
era como pretender escuchar un susurro en un concierto de heavy metal,
es decir, muy difícil.
Intenté de muchas maneras,
pero tras un mes de trabajo, me di cuenta de algo:
no podía lograrlo, tenía que desistir.
Y debía informarle a este otro científico que los datos eran muy confusos,
no podíamos determinar si esto era o no un planeta.
Y eso fue difícil.
Tiempo después, obtuvimos observaciones adicionales
en las que se veía que no se trataba de un planeta,
sino de algo similar a una estrella o galaxia.
No quiero sonar muy técnico, pero no fue nada divertido.
(Risas)
Me sentí muy descontento.
Pero es parte del proceso, hay que admitir:
"No podemos hacer esto con los datos que tenemos".
Y luego debía admitir que hasta la información adicional
demostró que nos habíamos equivocado.
Emocionalmente, estaba muy descontento.
Pero para un científico que realiza su trabajo correctamente,
equivocarse no es tan malo,
porque significa que aún hay cosas por descubrir, más cosas por develar.
A los científicos no nos gusta equivocarnos, pero sí los rompecabezas,
y el universo es el rompecabezas más grande que existe.
Habiendo aclarado eso,
si tienen una pieza que no encaja de ninguna forma,
intentar que encaje a la fuerza no va a ayudar.
Hay casos en los que deben abandonar una idea individual
si pretenden comprender el panorama completo.
El precio a pagar por hacer ciencia es admitir cuando uno se equivoca,
pero la recompensa es lo mejor que existe: conocimiento y entendimiento.
Y puedo darles miles de ejemplos de esto en la ciencia,
pero hay uno que me gusta mucho.
Es del área de astronomía,
y se trató de un interrogante que agobió a los astrónomos durante siglos.
Cuando miran el Sol, parece especial, es lo más brillante en el cielo.
Pero habiendo estudiado astronomía, física, química y termodinámica
por siglos,
aprendimos algo muy importante al respecto.
No es tan especial.
Es una estrella similar a millones de otras estrellas.
Pero esto plantea una pregunta interesante:
si el Sol es una estrella y tiene planetas,
¿las otras estrellas tienen también planetas?
Como mencioné en mi caso, con el 'planeta' que estaba buscando,
encontrarlos es muy difícil.
Aun así los científicos,
quienes suelen ser personas inteligentes y usan muchas técnicas diferentes,
comenzaron a observar las estrellas.
Y, con el correr de los años,
comenzaron a descubrir cosas súperinteresantes,
justo en ese margen minúsculo de lo que podía detectarse.
Pero se equivocaban una y otra vez.
Todo esto cambió en 1991.
Un par de astrónomos,
Andrew Lyne y Matthew Bailes,
hicieron un anuncio importante:
habían encontrado un planeta que orbitaba alrededor de otra estrella.
Y no una estrella común, sino una púlsar.
Se trata de los restos de una estrella que ha hecho implosión
y que emite radiación.
Es el último rincón del universo donde se esperaría encontrar un planeta.
Pero habían analizado esta púlsar de forma metódica,
y detectaron la fuerza gravitacional de este planeta
a medida que orbitaba la púlsar.
Todo lucía muy bien.
Habían descubierto el primer planeta que orbitaba otra estrella.
Excepto que... no era así.
(Risas)
Después del anuncio,
muchos otros astrónomos comentaron al respecto,
así que analizaron una vez más sus datos
y se dieron cuenta de que habían cometido un error muy vergonzoso.
No habían tenido en cuenta unas características muy sutiles
del movimiento de la Tierra alrededor del Sol
que afectaba la medición del movimiento de este planeta alrededor de la púlsar.
Y resulta que, cuando las tomaron en cuenta,
puf, el planeta desapareció.
No existía.
Andrew Lyne tenía ahora una tarea formidable: debía admitir su error.
Así que en 1992, en una reunión de la Sociedad Astronómica Estadounidense,
una de las más grandes congregaciones de astrónomos del planeta,
se puso de pie y anunció que había cometido un error
y que el planeta no existía.
Y lo que pasó a continuación
--oh, me encanta esta parte--
fue maravilloso.
Lo ovacionaron.
Los astrónomos no estaban enfadados con él, no querían sancionarlo.
Lo elogiaron por su honestidad e integridad.
¡Eso me encanta!
Los científicos son seres humanos.
¡Y se pone mejor!
(Risas)
Lyne bajó del podio
y el siguiente en subir fue un hombre llamado Aleksander Wolszczan
quien tomó el micrófono y dijo:
"Sí, el equipo de Lyne no encontró un planeta de púlsar,
pero mi equipo encontró no uno sino dos planetas que orbitan otra púlsar.
Nos enteramos del problema de Lyne, lo revisamos, y los nuestros sí existen".
Y resulta que tenía razón.
Y unos pocos meses después,
encontraron un tercer planeta que orbitaba la púlsar
y se trató del primer sistema de exoplanetas descubierto,
lo que llamamos planetas extrasolares, exoplanetas.
Eso me parece simplemente fascinante.
En ese momento se abrieron muchas puertas.
En 1995 se encontró un planeta alrededor de una estrella más similar al Sol,
y luego descubrimos otro y otro más.
En esta imagen ven un planeta de verdad que orbita una estrella de verdad.
Seguimos mejorando.
Comenzamos a encontrarlos en cantidades, encontramos miles de estos planetas.
Construimos observatorios especialmente diseñados para buscarlos.
Y hoy día conocemos miles de ellos.
Incluso conocemos un sistema planetario.
Esta información animada nos muestra cuatro planetas que orbitan otra estrella.
Esto es increíble. Piénsenlo un momento.
Durante toda la historia de la humanidad,
podían contar todos los planetas del universo con los dedos de dos manos:
nueve... ¿ocho?
¿Nueve? Ocho... Ocho.
(Risas)
Pero ahora sabemos que están por todas partes.
Por cada estrella que ven en el cielo podría haber tres, cinco, diez planetas.
El firmamento está lleno de planetas.
Pensamos que puede haber más planetas que estrellas en la galaxia.
Ésta es una afirmación importante, que se hizo gracias a la ciencia.
No sólo gracias a la ciencia, los observatorios y los datos;
sino gracias a los científicos que crearon los observatorios, recolectaron los datos,
cometieron errores, los admitieron
y posibilitaron así que otros científicos aprendieran de estos errores,
hicieran su trabajo
y descubrieran cuál es nuestro lugar en el universo.
(Risas)
Así es cómo se descubre la verdad.
La ciencia funciona mejor cuando se atreve a ser humana.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)